très bien merci la parole est à Gérard
Longuet pour le groupe UMP
oui monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur Laurent Fabius notre ministre
des Affaires étrangères qui est absent à
cet instant je suis persuadé que nous
aurons une réponse
l'opposition en général et l'UMP en
particulier
lorsque la France est engagée à
l'étranger
s'efforce de soutenir son autorité
et considère que les divisions
partisanes légitimes d'ailleurs
ne doivent en aucun cas l'emporter c'est
une attitude dont nous ne nous
débarquerons pas c'est pourquoi nous
avons soutenu l'intervention au Mali
nous soutenons à cet instant
l'intervention en RCA
et au nom de l'autorité de la France
nous avions émis des doutes sur les
déclarations du président de la
République concernant la Syrie je dois
constater que ces doutes étaient fondées
il la lui même constaté d'ailleurs peu
après
ma question concerne l'Ukraine
nous souhaitons non pas faire le procès
de ce pays qui est connu et hélas connu
par ses excès et par ses échecs mais
nous voudrions connaître l'attitude du
président de la République et celle du
gouvernement au regard d'une crise qui
concerne toute l'Europe
et qui concerne les relations de
l'Europe avec ce grand voisin
qui a été à la fois notre grand allié et
parfois notre grande menace lorsque
c'était l'Union soviétique je parle de
la Russie
il y a manifestement dans la crise
ukrainienne un choix
quelle est la volonté du gouvernement
français quelle est la volonté du
Président de la République de peser dans
cette crise et en particulier
et ma question s'articule autour de
trois demandes
aurons-nous la clarté de Madame Merkel
et de sa majorité
pour manifester aux côtés des partisans
de l'Europe où nous contenterons nous
d'inviter monsieur vitaliclichko à venir
déjeuner à Paris ce qui d'ailleurs un
geste élégant mais insuffisant la
deuxième question à très à la demande
même présentée par le gouvernement de
Kiev lors du sommet de villenieux le 29
novembre dernier s'agit-il pour vous
d'un chantage absolu cherchant la
rupture ou d'une demande d'un pays en
désarroi la troisième et dernière
question
au fond quel est votre politique
vis-à-vis de la Russie nous annoncer le
centenaire de la Première Guerre
mondiale l'année prochaine l'alliance
franco-rus est un facteur de solidité en
Europe nous aimerions connaître quels
jugement la France porte sur le droit de
la Russie de s'organiser à côté de
l'Europe et peut-elle s'organiser avec
l'Europe en évitant tout conflit inutile
merci Monsieur Thierry reporter
sur le sénateur langage je vous remercie
de votre question qui me permet aussi de
revenir sur un déplacement que j'ai
effectué le 5 décembre donc il y a
quelques jours à Kiev ou je me suis
rendu sur la Place de l'Indépendance
pour discuter avec les manifestants
avant de rencontrer d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des représentants de
l'opposition ainsi que la famille de
Madame Timochenko les manifestations qui
ont lieu quotidiennement à Kiev depuis
plus d'une dizaine de jours appel de la
France trois mots d'ordre je veux être
précis le premier mot d'ordre c'est
l'appel à la non-violence plusieurs
centaines de milliers de personnes
manifestent jour et nuit effectivement
dans la capitale ukrainienne dans un
climat de tension qui a fait de nombreux
blessés y compris d'ailleurs chez les
journalistes qui couvrent cet événement
les forces de l'ordre
dans les derniers jours tenter des
opérations d'évacuation même si la nuit
dernière a été effectivement plus calme
ceci étant la France appelle au respect
du droit de manifester et à la plus
grande retenue nous ne le disons aux
autorités gouvernementales rien ne sera
possible
si la paix civile n'est pas assurée les
revendications qui s'expriment sont
pacifiques j'en ai été témoin elles
doivent donc être traitées pacifiquement
le deuxième mot d'ordre c'est celui de
la reprise du dialogue d'un côté le
président
yanocovitch accepte le principe d'une
conciliation et de l'autre il déploie
des forces de l'ordre dans le
centre-ville refuse d'être dialoguer
avec l'opposition il faut c'est
nécessaire et je pense que nous pouvons
être tous d'accord que le dialogue soit
renoué entre le gouvernement et les
oppositions qui sont dans la rue c'est
l'objet de l'échange d'ailleurs qui a eu
lieu hier entre Laurent Fabius et
Monsieur Klitschko lequel doit être
aussi respecter et écouter comme
porte-parole des revendications du
peuple
ukrainien et le troisième mot d'ordre
c'est la volonté d'ouverture de l'Union
européenne
vers l'Ukraine qui reste totalement
intact nous donnerons favorable à
l'accord d'association avec l'Ukraine le
président de la République lui-même l'a
dit à Vilnius à l'occasion du sommet du
Partenariat oriental mais l'Europe ce
n'est pas qu'une affaire de marchand de
tapis par rapport à ce que pourrait
offrir ou non telle ou tel autre
puissance l'Ukraine n'est pas acheté
comme l'Europe n'est pas à vendre je
veux d'ailleurs souligner qu'à nos yeux
il n'y a pas d'antagonisme entre la
signature d'un accord d'association avec
l'Europe et le fait d'être proche de la
Russie c'est un message que nous a vont
passer à la partie ukrainienne c'est la
mission qui était devenue à Madame
Ashton au don de l'Union européenne non
violence dialogue maintien de
l'ouverture européenne c'est ça notre
position et c'est au peuple
ukrainien dont le droit de manifester
doit être pleinement respecté de dire
pacifiquement quelle est la sienne merci
monsieur le ministre